first of all I'd like to thank the
organizers for assembly was gathering
hand for last
I've screwed some little try my best to
speak more or less one approach to which
we would see has some resonances with
the kinds of things that might fellow
panelists have already settled one fear
that I might be a bit more open and more
gestural and sketchy that they have so
eloquently being I'm too I'm going to
essay this approach in relation to a
single text namely the wretched of the
earth and that's because for me anyway
the horizon in relation to which I want
to think about the world of transferrin
is that event colonial sovereignty and
Antonia self-determination
and it's into that final the rest of
garage in particular we see speaks
eloquently from and to Horizon
because as we all know the wretched of
the earth is written in a moment of
enormous and intense urgency urgency at
once political proclaiming the closing
years of as union war of independence
and of personal urgency the closing
years of violence and it hits me that
that shapes to enlarge the architecture
of the register
Rosa says somewhere I think MMSE on
death but he had written to Samuel
Beckett who was a regular evolutional
times and her mother who writes the
funds to some herb ethics and asks him
to explain to him the character is right
and Beckett's rights back tomorrow so
saying that I I was once in a hospital
and the man in bed next to me who was
dying of cancer
screaming dormant that screaming is
structure
there is a screen that is that
constitutes the structure
but approach that I want to to burn
sketchily as I see si saluted by asking
for what's the question
Oh
- it's the mention of the earth to which
the wretched of the earth to my mind the
answer to that is not self-evident we
think obviously that we know in advance
now on this side of the act of the
inclusion project that we knew the
answer to that question not self-evident
the same relation to the horizon of
expectation to finance products is
we look back in the wake of what I like
to call and bundling projects
we go back from the ruins toward finally
looking up toward with caution or but a
possibility a possibility which we don't
separate
so to my mind the conceptual about
illogical shape of finals question of
Anna's question about colonialism has to
be reconstructed has any critical
and yes may be constructed to enable two
things to enable us to understand the
character the internal character of
Alan's project it's the internal
question answer in problem space within
which final frame his project first
I'm not on secondly to enable us from
the present that we have to discern
whether or not extend panels questions
I won't suggest them I'm recommending
very sketchy and very very schematic
here but we need to ask ourselves what
was the future of colonialism that final
construction
what imagine the ill effects of chronium
the harm
granted in the aftermath of building
missions in advance for the answers to
that question
some of picture of of colonialism as
picture of what colonialism is my
wretched of the earth emerge support as
my fellow panelists just generally
physically in the chapter
not just the first chapter of violence
but also in the penultimate chapter on
psychology
no these are limit chapters that the
chapter on sack mythology of war is my
house family
the first session of the structure
undoubtedly as we all know and this is
the chapter that through which that
creates the lens through which we
imagine the apostle of violence and I
often have in mind
Kenard ends furious discussion of
incorrectly unbalanced um there are some
reason which that will come back later
on
now in the approach that I want to
suggest to you
that'll be eating for finals questions
we want to read this opening chapter
concerning bad
not four or less for the ceiling idea
that violence is an anti-colonial answer
you remember as has been suggested that
trial opens that chapter to several
marvelous passages on decolonization as
an event of violence as it says and he
gives you his response he gives us and
polio and I'm suggesting that this
chapter wanted to be read less within
the frame of that answer then for what
it suggests about panels understanding
of our prophet
so less from advantage that
decolonization is herself an event of
violence than before his argument that
close living with itself with a
structure of absolute totalizing
and for funnel
and I'm not even recording and I wish I
could but there is one passage the other
remains in my mind about colonialism as
systemic violence which is where my
knowledge there's I think just two
sentences before one thoughts that you
had the colonialism is not thinking
thinking about in doubt is making fire
and for fun
so it's noticeable it is notice over
here
it's like Rotom on our ends and
hammerings book on violence that follows
not seeing the communism is a structure
of overwhelming power it's not seeing
that pluralism is an abuse of authority
it is not that colonialism is about
unequal strength all cells they're
losing is systemic totalizing
the rest of the earth
what's our tax rise this violence
violence Buddhism is not violence of
nearly marks the body of the continent
or destroys that
for fun or crucially from the violence
isn't violence that looks inside of and
takes hold of the molecular structure of
the water it gets hold of the molecular
structure of the body and transforms
falls organization what is dispositions
what is active units
remember those passages in which final
talks about the muscular tension Coulomb
island ii live for panel is in violence
that reorganizes the structures of
effect and design
the transforms and reorganizes
structures of fantasy of dreaming and
design of the car
like CC important to understand that
there for four finalists animal violence
the questionable garden is not about the
paternity of the estate little fetus
unions divorce
that is a question for what violence
does is fight
what violence does is needed and what is
sadly today McGinty is the bodily and
psychological integrity
with her eggs on standby as marriage and
Palestine with relations whereas for
this is in many ways from sexual
violence that he shares from South that
violence is embedded as a kind of in the
remission
so
I want you in that one or two meet for
final question that one ought to be for
me in which the conception of violence
emerges back off and has to be read
through family understanding on message
and I'm arguing that this conception of
violence is one in which the body of our
colonizers and the psyche of colonized
are what are the types of colonial - and
I'm arguing that question of violence is
not about mentality as such murder and
death the question here is not whether
or not this is a true picture of
the issue here for us as readers as
critically doesn't transfer whether an
oxidation picture was using
was whatever that was probable you are
imagining to have
the crucial crucial question for the
approach that I want to suggest to you
is what worked intimate romantic are
sources which this picture of humility
emerges and I don't want electrolyte
illogical problem space in which the
problem of violence and more broadly the
problem of colonialism as pirates and
secondly
what rhetorical effects there's this
construction of problem of colonialism
have form in which we understand or
imagine the matter of collisions of that
figuring of colonialism and colonial
violence for more phenol wants us to
imagine what the aftermath of resentment
what imagination loves of colonialism
are inscribed in that particular texture
image to bring on